y
[Música]
la calidad de nuestras relaciones y la
calidad de nuestra vida en general
depende de la calidad de nuestras
conversaciones
te quiero proponer un ejercicio mental
evoca la última discusión que has tenido
en tu ambiente profesional personal o
incluso en tu vida social
qué emociones experimentaste
pudiste explicar de manera clara lo que
querías argumentar
logras de explicar tus ideas de forma
clara
comprendiste la postura de la otra
persona y te sentiste comprendida o
comprendido al mismo tiempo seguramente
puedes reconocer algunas emociones como
la frustración por no poder construir
puentes de acuerdo la impotencia de no
poder explicar qué es lo que tenías tú
en la cabeza o sencillamente la
decepción de que las personas actúan no
responden de una manera improvisada o
distinta a la que tú esperabas de ellas
pues bien estas frustraciones todas
vienen de un problema de comunicación de
un problema en el que hemos construido a
la palabra y la hemos esclavizado por
nuestros miedos por nuestras malas
actitudes porque estamos dispuestos para
dialogar o sencillamente porque no
logramos comunicarnos de manera concreta
de manera clara y sobre todo de manera
respetuosa
estos problemas están presentes en todas
las relaciones humanas si pensamos en
los principales problemas que nos
aquejan como sociedad violencia
discriminación abuso de poder se
encuentra también una incapacidad de
dialogar una incapacidad de conversar y
es más aunado a esto hoy en la pandemia
vivimos con una preocupación por nuestra
salud una preocupación por nuestros
seres queridos y la distancia física
interminable de no poder estar con las
personas con las que queremos
comunicarnos
necesitamos desconfiar a la palabra para
así poder liberar su poder transformador
mi nombre es adán aguilar soy filósofo y
educador te quiero compartir tres
aptitudes prácticas para que podamos
transformar nuestra capacidad de palabra
y para que podamos desconfiar y liberar
ese poder transformador que tiene el
lenguaje la primera de ellas es muy
sencilla es la actitud práctica de la
disponibilidad
a continuación te comparto la imagen del
hombre de vitruvio este diagrama hecho
por leonardo da vinci muy famoso sabemos
que los pintores de renacimiento se
inspiraron en los cánones de la belleza
griegos y allá en la antigua grecia se
hablaba de la importancia de la armonía
de que todas las partes de una pintura y
en la naturaleza las partes de un cuerpo
las partes de un animal las partes del
cosmos todas guardaban armonía entre sí
y podemos ver en esta pintura de
leonardo como la cabeza tiene una
proporción con el tronco con las manos
con los brazos
proporciones armónicas el cuerpo está
dispuesto de manera abierta y armónica
pues bien
en primer lugar uno de los bloqueos que
ocurre con mayor frecuencia para poder
dialogar es se basa en mi disponibilidad
corporal
yo mismo pongo bloqueos en mi propio
cuerpo a veces nos olvida que estamos
hablando desde lo que somos que somos un
cuerpo entonces cuántas veces no les ha
pasado a alguien que dice quiero ser muy
sincero contigo pero está cruzado de
brazos de piernas y ni siquiera te ve
eso no me está dando una noción de
apertura y de disponibilidad
cuántas veces estamos en una posición en
donde nos falta aire estamos encorvado
no podemos escuchar bien o no estamos
dirigidos a la persona que nos está
hablando y de esta manera estamos dando
señales de indisponibilidad no estoy
disponible para recibir tu mensaje qué
pasaría si mejoro mi posición mi postura
de forma abierta de forma estable de
forma vertical porque así le daré a la
audiencia a quien me está escuchando que
estoy atendiendo que estoy abierto a
compartir con esas personas pero también
estaré diciendo mi cerebro que no hay
peligro
primero cuidar la disponibilidad de mi
cuerpo para que mi propio cuerpo no se
convierta en un estorbo no se convierta
en un bloqueo hablando de la
disponibilidad tenemos un segundo nivel
la disponibilidad emocional
cuántas veces nos acercamos a una
conferencia a una plática a una
presentación oa una conversación de uno
a uno pero tenemos una emoción que nos
nos aprieta el estómago y no nos permite
liberar nuestra capacidad para dialogar
cuántas veces no hemos sido esclavos de
una emoción que prima sobre todo lo
demás que quería decir o que quería
comunicar
qué emociones pueden ser el enojo miedo
rabia preocupación o emociones positivas
también alegría urgencia excitabilidad
todas estas emociones si son tan
intensas que hacen que mi palabra se
quede constreñido no me van a permitir
dejar un libre fluir de la conversación
para poder darle su lugar a las
emociones necesito tomar una cierta
distancia crítica un espacio recordamos
mucho cuando de pequeño nos decían antes
de dialogar y si estás enfadada o
enfadado
respira y cuenta hasta 10
esta respiración no es un truco no es
magia sencillamente le estamos diciendo
a nuestra afectividad toma un descanso
no rechaces la emoción
vela de cara a cara acepta la y ahora sí
con esa distancia de ok si estoy
enfadado si estoy triste si estoy muy
emocionado con esa distancia crítica
ahora revisa un criterio esa emoción te
va a servir para conversar si estás
dentro de un enojo muy intenso de un
enfado muy intenso ese enfado te va a
servir para conversar lo más probable es
que no pero bueno ya decidirás tú si te
ayuda
en otros momentos y de pronto esa
emoción te ayuda por ejemplo una emoción
de preocupación por la otra persona te
ayuda y te motiva a salir al encuentro
de la otra persona y explicar lo que te
mueve lo que te mueve y lo que quieres
comunicar en ese sentido esa emoción
tendrá un buen uso vamos no a negar a
las emociones oa ignorar las vamos a
reconocer las vamos a tomar distancia de
ellos y es más vamos a usarlas en una
decisión consciente
tu cuerpo dispuesto tus emociones
dispuestas y ahora tus pensamientos tu
disposición intelectual y aquí más bien
me quiero referir a la capacidad de
reconocer que la otra persona también me
va a dar razones también tiene algo que
compartir me y también me va a dar
argumentos
entonces tengo la capacidad intelectual
de reconocer que lo que yo digo puede no
ser la verdad que lo que diga la otra
persona puede estar también llena de
razón
esta disposición intelectual es
sencillamente una disposición de
honestidad la honestidad te va a
permitir estar así como tu cuerpo esté
abierto y así como tus emociones están
enfocadas tu intelecto también estará
dispuesto a dialogar a reconocer errores
y a seguir la conversación
por último pensar en esta idea no el
diálogo su etimología significa díaz a
través de un recorrido y luego razón
palabra tratado estudio generemos
diálogos es decir que haya razón que va
y viene y no monólogos al mismo tiempo
en donde cada quien habla de una cosa y
parece que estamos dialogando solamente
porque coincide que tú hablas al mismo
tiempo que yo pero eso no es una
disposición intelectual de apertura
entonces preguntémonos a nosotros mismos
qué tan dispuesto estoy para dialogar
que tan dispuesto estás para dialogar tu
cuerpo tus emociones y los pensamientos
que vas a traer a esta conversación
muy bien la segunda actitud práctica que
quiero compartir con ustedes es la de la
claridad ahora bien ustedes podrían
pensar vaya a hablar de la claridad
realmente pues es muy obvio tener claras
mis ideas
sin embargo conviene pensar que la
claridad
e implica un ejercicio de como decirlo
poner transparente lo que tengo atrás
poner transparentes las razones por las
cuales te quiero decir lo que te quiero
decir como un cristal que es claro
primero dar razones de lo que quieres
decir puede ser que tú tengas muy claro
que quieres compartir con ese
colaborador en tu trabajo esta nueva
idea para el negocio pero si no lo
soporta con de dónde viene con esa
claridad argumentativa la otra persona
no lo va a entender
muchas veces bloqueamos nuestra palabra
porque no sabemos ni siquiera qué es eso
que queremos comunicar estamos hablando
de descripciones de la realidad hablamos
también de declaraciones esto es de una
manera esto es de otra y también de
juicios y de argumentaciones esto
debería ser así
por esto caminemos en ese sentido dar
razones y no solamente disparar una
serie de hechos dar razones número uno
número dos para ser claro no solamente
dar razones sino que necesitas traducir
te a veces empezamos a discutir con una
persona y cuando termina la discusión
decimos espera creo que estábamos
hablando de lo mismo y estamos
discutiendo por solamente terminología
si yo logro traducir mis ideas de tal
forma que la otra persona lo entienda y
entonces construyó un suelo común las
ideas van a fluir de manera más clara
y por último el tercer punto aquí te
quiero compartir una serie de
señalizaciones que aparecen en el camino
de santiago es una peregrinación muy
antigua en donde gente de toda europa
camina hasta llegar a santiago de
compostela al norte de españa'
si ves esta señalización bueno aparece
una concha aparece una flecha parece que
no nos dice mucho de por dónde va el
camino de hecho los peregrinos no suelen
llevar mapas y más bien lo que hacen es
seguir estas señalizaciones que aparecen
en pequeñas piedras en la puerta de un
pequeño poblado en la calle o en un
árbol inclusive y lo cuelgan ahí en ese
sentido conviene pensar que nuestro
diálogo es una trayectoria necesito
tener claro a dónde quiero llegar y las
direcciones específicas de por dónde
moverme
porque no usamos un mapa porque en la
conversación no tenemos todo escrito de
lo que le voy a decir es esto esto esto
porque muchas veces lo que nos contestan
es inesperado así como en un mapa de
pronto tú puedes tener el mapa y aparece
cuando vas caminando una montaña o un
río que no estaba especificada el mapa
no es el territorio para llegar a dónde
quieres llegar con la claridad de tu
mensaje define tu punto de llegada y
también traza ciertas trayectorias
por lo tanto pregúntate a ti mismo qué
tan claro tienes lo que vas a decir das
razón de ello lo traduces a un suelo
común de comprensión
sabes a dónde quieres llegar la tercera
actitud práctica es la actitud del
respeto esto parece muy obvio y parece
que el respeto pues bueno debería estar
en la base de todas nuestras relaciones
sociales sin embargo a veces entendemos
el respeto como una cierta distancia de
bueno ella esta persona hace lo que hace
yo hago lo que hago y listo
hay una película en netflix que se llama
mi maestro el pulpo es una película muy
bella que te recomiendo que las revises
porque en esa película un buzo de la
costa de sudáfrica se sumerge durante
360 días casi un año diariamente a un
arrecife cercano para ver cómo vive un
pequeño pulpo hembra está pulpo pues
empieza a crecernos desde que es
pequeñita hasta que es madre y este
personaje este buzo va diariamente y lo
busca y entonces quiere comprender cómo
vive ese pulpo sumergiéndose a su nivel
pensemos en el respeto de esa manera
pensemos en el respeto en el sumergirnos
en el mismo hábitat que la otra persona
en el mismo dinamismo propio para poder
hacerlo el pulpo necesitaba pues bueno
tener un espacio libre su en su propio
hábitat si el buzo hubiera querido
conocer al pulpo y lo hubiera sacado de
su hábitat si lo hubiera pescado o lo
hubiera puesto en una vitrina no hubiera
conocido en verdad la naturaleza de este
animal de la misma manera nosotros
bloqueamos nuestra capacidad de
conversación cuando queremos meter a las
personas en ciertas etiquetas etiquetas
de nacionalidad de carácter de de a lo
que te dedicas de tu mismo nombre
etiquetamos a las personas y esa
etiqueta parece ser meter a la persona
en una vitrina saca a la persona de la
vitrina y conócela en su hábitat conoce
a la persona en su dinamismo propio el
buzo no dejó de ser buzo y de hecho
tenía que salir a cada momento para
tomar aire el pulpo no dejó de ser pulpo
es decir
empatizar con otra persona no significa
simpatizar y creer lo mismo que la otra
cree o argumentar lo mismo que la otra
argumenta
pero lo que sí implica el respeto es la
aceptación de que la otra persona es
libre en su forma de ser y autónoma en
su forma de actuar preguntémonos a
nosotros mismos que tan respetuosa está
siendo mi conversación que tan
respetuosas están siendo mis
conversaciones estoy dejando que la otra
persona explique sus puntos estoy
consciente de lo que dice esa persona
tiene una validez
pues bien con estas tres actitudes la
actitud de la disponibilidad cuerpo
emociones y pensamientos la actitud de
la claridad de manera que tenga razones
por las que estoy diciendo lo que estoy
diciendo construya puentes en común y me
traduzca y tenga clara la trayectoria y
el lugar a donde quiero llegar y con la
actitud práctica del respeto activo de
reconocer a la persona en su hábitat en
su propia naturaleza podremos construir
relaciones más empáticas y relaciones
más efectivas si queremos mejorar la
calidad de nuestras relaciones y por lo
tanto la calidad de nuestra vida
necesitamos desconfiar a la palabra
[Música]